this optical illusion is called
simultaneous brightness contrast the dot
appears to become brighter as I move it
up and darker as I move it down even
though its color never changes and
believe it or not we still don't know
what causes it all we know is that
somehow somewhere in the brain we
forfeit Truth for exaggerated contrast
difference recent Studies have suggested
that we may be born to make this mistake
and that makes sense it may be an error
but it may also help us more quickly
distinguish features in the environment
natural selection may have favored this
over accuracy because sometimes it's
more important to live than to see
reality as it is
thank you